Hi, Steve Kaufmann here and today,
I want to talk about how I study
Italian or how I learned Italian.
Uh, remember if you enjoy
these videos, please subscribe.
And if you've listen to podcasts, on a
podcast service, please leave a review.
Uh, I do appreciate it.
Now, uh, I did a video on what I did
to learn German, how I studied German,
how I learned German to the extent
that I speak German, because it's
not one of my strongest languages.
Now I'm going to do the same with Italian.
And, um, I don't, I haven't scoured
all my bookshelves to find all the
books that I, I used for Italian, but
the process was essentially the same.
And now it is again, you
know, I had traveled in Italy.
I had hitchhiked, uh, hitchhiked
in Italy, uh, with the knowledge of
Spanish that I had, I was kind of
communicating with people in Italy.
Uh, and it's always a language that
had, you know, a great appeal to me
because Italy is such a lovely country.
There's so many lovely places to visit
and food and music and lively people.
And so I wanted to be good in Italian.
And of course I wasn't,
I was communicate...
communicating, but at a very basic level.
So, I can't remember when I decided
to make a greater effort with
my Italian, but I will show you
some of the things that I did.
So, first of all, the one thing I
remember is that I got a hold of
the Linguaphone series for Italian.
And Linguaphone is, I don't know if
they still exist, I guess they do.
It's extremely expensive for what it
is, because essentially what you need
is text with audio and a glossary.
That's all you need.
You don't need all the exercises.
It's fashionable now to have
pre-reading questions and post-reading
comprehension questions, and all kinds
of things that are quite unnecessary.
In fact, that spoil the
pleasure of reading.
Uh, so there's a lot of useless
exercise stuff in here, but I had
to find something for Italian.
So I don't know if I got a deal on it
or if it was sort of surplus somewhere.
But I do know that I went through this and
listened to the audio many, many times.
And this was before I got into this, you
know, the realization that you have to
listen repetitively over and over again,
instinctively that's something I did.
And I can remember listening when
the family arrived in Milan and
vaguely, this would be at least
30 years ago that I did this.
So I went through this.
Now, um, then with my experience in
German of finding, you know, readers with
glossaries, um, you know, I found books
like this First Itlaian Reader for Adults.
And I have never liked, I do have,
I don't know where they are here.
I can find them, you know, sort of
bilingual books where you have, let's
say the Italian on the left-hand side
and the English on the right-hand side.
I've never found that very effective
because what I need is the words, the
individual words that I don't understand,
I don't want to have to read through
the English to find the spot that
corresponds to where I am in the Italian.
What I want is like, here's this
word I don't know what it means.
What does it mean?
And in former days that meant, uh,
you know, readers with glossaries.
As I showed you for German, the
disadvantage is that very often, the
word you need is not in their glossary
or the word that they introduced in the
glossary is a word you already know.
So to a large extent that has now been
made obsolete by online dictionaries,
by LingQ and things of that nature.
But I did a lot of reading
of, and I just couldn't find
them, but oh, here we have...
here's another one.
But there were lots of more
and, and, uh, always, you
know, readings with glossaries.
Now, obviously, if you know French,
if you know Spanish, a lot of
vocabulary is freebie in Italian.
People always make a big
deal about false friends.
To me, there is the odd false
friend in these languages.
It's not a big deal.
The common vocabulary is a much greater
benefit in learning a language and
the odd word that is a false friend.
You quickly find out if you
use it in the wrong context.
And so you make adjustments, but it's...
false friends, in other words,
a common vocabulary is a
good thing not a bad thing.
Um, but with the Italian...
now grammar, of course, this is a
great little grammar book, which you
go back, I go back to over and over
and over again, because all the little
pronouns ... and that, uh, are difficult
because they're different, different from
what I am used to in other languages.
And so kind of reviewed the rules and then
you watch for them when you're reading
and then you listen and stuff like that.
A big, a big boost to my Italian was
the discovery of il narratore, which is
a, an audio book publisher, very small
based near, um, I think he's near, uh,
Verona, uh, but he's up on the hillside.
And he's there and he puts out wonderful,
uh, audio books and he does a wonderful
rendering of  I promessi sposi.
Now, a lot of people, especially
Italian people, they had,  I promessi
sposi, which is a classic of Italian
literature, they had it at school.
They don't like it.
It's boring, but for me, it's what I like.
It's exotic.
It's another century.
It's another country.
And of course, with, uh, the wonderful,
uh, audio book version that...
mauricio does, it's lovely.
And I can remember jogging when
I was in Palm Springs, listening
to I promessi sposi in Italian.
He also does a wonderful version
of wonderful version of Pinocchio.
And the advantage with both those texts
is that I can import the text to LingQ.
I can look at words and phrases.
So I'm no longer a, you know, in many
cases, you know, if you get a book
like a modern book like this, Alberto
Moravia, uh, there won't be, uh, you
know, you can't just get the digital
text to import to LingQ, but if you're
dealing with, um, classics, you can
import the text, look up words and
phrases, you can listen to the audio.
And so you're learning in a way
that's agreeable, it's easy.
That's much easier than struggling
with bilingual textbooks or even
books with, with glossaries.
So that was my path with Italian.
And, but I'm not where
I want to be in Italian.
For example, if I want to read
Umberto Eco, which I do, there are too
many words that I don't understand.
And so if I start reading them and if
I look through this book, I'll see a
lot of underlinings where, you know,
I underlined the word with the sort of
optimistic intention of eventually looking
it up at a dictionary, which I never do.
Um, ideally I would be able to read those
on LingQ so I can look up every word and
save words and phrases and learn them.
So with that, I'll just show you a
very brief, uh, what I have done with
Italian on LingQ, and then I'll kind
of, uh, finish up with a few words.
Okay.
Let's have a look at what I've
been doing in LingQ, which has
really made the learning of a...
of any language, including Italian a lot
easier than it was 30 years ago when I
decided to improve my level of Italian.
So if I click on my thumbnail here and,
um, No, I haven't done anything recently,
but if I go to my all time will see that
I have 22,500 or 22,236, known words that
I was particularly active terms of adding
to my known words total back in 2008
and have been active at various times.
Uh, this is the known words.
Now, if I look at my LingQs created
number there's only 5,000 of them,
so that the bulk of the words that
are on my known words total are words
that I saw in the text, but didn't
need to look up cause I knew them.
And so I think eventually sort of
determines what your vocabulary
level is as you will go by saving
words that you need to learn.
Uh, if I look at words of reading that
I've done on LingQ, I hadn't read a
fair amount, but I've also read a lot
of Italian away from LingQ so LingQ
hasn't been my main, um, place to study
Italian, although, you know, 61,000
words back in the summer, I guess
the end of 2013 is not insignificant.
Uh, but, uh, that gives you, so I
found out that the gradual growth
in my known words, And picked up
a lot at the beginning and have
continued to increase gradually, but
I really haven't been very active.
So that's really the picture
of my activity, uh, when it
comes to Italian on LingQ.
So, um, you know, where do I want
to get to with, with Itlaian?
You know, I can communicate in Italian,
uh, to some extent, but not as well as I
would, like, I don't speak it as well as
I would like, I understand quite well.
Uh, but if I pick up a book like this,
like, uh, I have actually, uh, I think, I
think this is one where I found the audio
book, so I could listen to the audiobook
of what if I read through it on every page
I can see because I've underlined them.
I can see five or six or
so words that I don't know.
So I'm not good at it.
In my reading, I would like to be better.
And if I weren't learning Arabic
and Persian, then just as with all
the other languages, I would love to
spend time to get better in Italian.
But I have sort of brought my
Italian up to a level where it's
not just sort of semi Spanish.
It's actually Italian but limited.
And, but I am at a situation where if
I were to go to Italy or if I've had
the opportunity or the need to use the
language, or if I just decided to spend
a month indulging in my interest and
the enjoyment that I get from Italian,
that I could, you know, bring it up.
And so it's kind of on
the same level as German.
In other words, a rusty B2
that I could easily bring up
to a, a better level of B2.
And that's where I hope
to get my language.
As I continue to explore new languages, I
will leave you with a couple of interviews
that I've done in Italian so that you
can gauge, you know, the difficulties
that I continue to have in Italian.
Thank you for listening.